- I, actually would tell you
I fascinate sometimes over
losing everything and then
having you guys write articles
like see he wasn't that good.
He was a fully shit and then
rising like a phoenix and being
like, "Fuck you!"
(audience laughter)
("OHZ by LRYBRDBTZ)
- [Woman] Coffee--
- [Gary] Yes, that'd be great.
- [Woman] food?
- [Gary] Thank you.
Nice view, huh?
(audience applause)
Thank you.
Good morning.
You it's funny I was in
Mexico City there was some
sort of speaker,
just really intelligent,
I didn't understand a word he
was saying but one of things he
said was 85%
of what we do
is irrational.
And it was a really interesting
moment for me because when we
talk about destruction and
change of things of that nature,
you have to understand my dad
was made fun of constantly in
1996 and seven by all his liquor
store friends for not opening a
second liquor store and letting
his son launch a website.
There're people in this room,
I'm looking at the age group,
that remember very strong
conversations in 1994 through
1998 that the
internet itself was a fad.
Not that Snapchat is a fad,
not that Vine or
Twitter is a fad.
That the whole
fucking platform was a fad.
We are living
through, this is for,
actually bear with
me for five minutes,
'cause I'm gonna be
talking to myself,
you're just gonna hear it.
(audience laughter)
We are living through a far
bigger culture shift than
anybody in this room,
including myself, realizes.
- How do you balance
your own signal to noise?
How's this room supposed to
figure out what to pay attention
to and what to disregard?
- I'm not sure but I know it's
gonna be the variable
of your success.
(audience laughter)
Right? I don't know, hey, you're
asking like how do we make good
strategic decisions that
become the framework of where we
dictate our behavior?
I don't know.
What I will tell you is it's
a lot more listening
than it is talking.
And I talk a lot.
I think you get a sense of my
energy like I'm always talking.
I've, DRock's
filming me right now.
I produce content
every single day.
I'm always talking but I'm
sneakily mainly paying attention
and so I produce content for
reaction so I can contextualize
that reaction and understand
the vibe of the ecosystem.
There are way too many
people building companies,
I'm talking to startups now,
I have a lot of passion for
this space,
you're building it in a silo.
Your building it for how you see
the world playing out without
spending a lot of time with
customers so I think the way
that you eliminate noise is go
to the source of what you want.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
("Sheppard" by LRYBRDBTZ)
- [Gary] Hey man.
Good to see you.
- Good to see you, too.
You talked earlier about that
client that wanted to reach 22
to 29-year-olds
with TV and radio.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah, yes.
- How'd you convince
them not to do that?
- [Gary] You know,
I don't convince anybody.
I tell them the only think you
can do in this environment is
Instagram and
Snapchat and
Facebook actually has
a lot more attention
of 20 to 30 than
the world realizes.
It's a very
take-it-or-leave-it thing.
I don't convince them.
My clients, as big as we
are, as much clout as I have,
as why would they hire Vayner,
are still probably executing in
the ballpark of
4 to 6% of our stuff.
- Really?
- [Gary] Really.
Think about that.
So, but, I don't spend any
energy on convincing people
that aren't convincible.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- [Gary] None.
It's just not a good game.
But you know what's fun?
I walk in with the same
energy that I walk here,
I fucking drill him, like Roman,
you have to fucking do this.
This is the only right thing and
then I guess I'm empathetic to
that I'm in client services like
there's plenty of places where
I get to make
the final decision.
In that environment, I don't and
what's really worked for me and
I think here's the real
punchline to give you real--
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm gonna win.
Like, the reason we're at
4 to 6% from 0% last year is
they saw that I was right.
How you doing?
How are you?
Very good, a pleasure.
I pretty much have
my life double mic'd.
I need to get a
double mic t-shirt, DRock.
I just think you have to
rethink the entire thing but to
break through the noise by
definition you have to do
something fundamentally
different than what everybody
else is doing and everybody
else is doing the same thing.
I call it the Taylor Swift role.
So, I think
Taylor Swift hacked culture.
I think Kanye does it as
well believe it or not.
Here's what they do.
You scale the unscalable if you
want to break through
the noise today.
So let me explain.
What Taylor Swift's very good at
is she knows when people tweet
her and say, "Taylor, come to
my wedding and sing me a song."
She actually does it.
Here's why she does it.
The 75 minute allocation of her
time to do something like that
is not ROI positive for Taylor
based on what
she makes for her time.
However, the amplification of
doing something that makes no
sense on paper is where
she gets all her value.
So, I get yelled at by
all my smartest CEO friends,
the most fancy gals and guys
on Earth for still answering all
these tweets and emails and
replying one by one on Snapchat
but I know that depth is far
more interesting than width in a
world where the width has just
become completely obnoxiously
loud and impossible
to break through.
The truth is there are
characters that look like
me running around.
There are people
that understand,
I know not that many, but you
can get somebody into an honest
conversation because they do
not have aligned interests.
They don't and the only,
they start the relationship with
knowing each other not at
all and that's the closest on
aligned interest they'll ever
be and this is all that happens.
And it breaks, so to me
let's just fucking
get it out of the way.
I just think
communication's very valuable.
Like it just works and
just nobody does it.
Like really.
I mean great communicators
win in life especially,
back to why married my wife five
seconds into our first date,
especially if you're lucky
enough to find another great
communicator and that's where
client relationships and that's
where business
partnerships start.
I just think it's better to know
that it's not a work up front.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
You know, for me all my diamonds
come from the friction of how
I see things versus how I'm
hearing everybody else talk
about them and so that's
where my practicality comes from
because the,
what I consider the irrational,
back to that, is helping
me understand listen,
just 'cause I this if the
consumer or the target is not
gonna go there it's not
gonna matter how I see it.
I mean I have no interest in
being historically right in
150 year window.
I'll be fuckin' dead.
- [Man 3] Right.
- Alright, take care guys.
Alright, ready?
Thank you.
- [Woman 2] Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Yeah, take
care of yourself.
Thank you.
Alright, we're stuck
in an elevator here.
(DRock laughs)
That's fun.
Listen, if I could,
and this is a DNA thing,
but anything I can do to
subtract emotion and romance out
of your body, I would.
- [Man 3] (inaudible) based
on passion at the beginning?
- The passion and delusion
are two very different things.
("Red C" by LRYBRDBTZ)